- Hmm, that's a good call.
- Yeah, I know.
- Thank you, he-hey.
(hands slap)
- Uh, what about the rest of us?
- Sorry dude, it's a two-for-one.
- Well, you could have made it uh --
Dammit.
- Oh my God, a four-for-two.
- No, that doesn't sound right.
- No. Your loss.
I sent out a mass email,
Charlie's the only one who replied,
ergo, he's my 4-1.
- Wait, but he paid for
it, so how is it your 4-1?
- Oh, because she told me
about the idea, so we're even.
- Yeah, that.
I'm just kidding, of
course we got some for you.
- [All] Hey!
- Well thanks.
- Aww, man.
- Don't thank me,
thank Charlie, it's all this guy.
- Thanks, Charlie.
- Thanks, buddy.
- It's what I do.
(slow guitar plucking)
- Hey, listen man,
no one else is gonna tell you this,
but I like to keep it real, ok?
You might want to start
carrying some gum around.
The boss told me the
only reason you're not
getting more accounts is
because of your bad breath.
(sniffs)
- Yeah.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I eat a lot of olives.
- So just keep some gum in your desk.
- Okay.
- Cool?
- Yeah.
- Alright.
(hands slap)
- Thanks.
- We're in this together.
(slow guitar plucking)
- Hey boss.
So I told everyone that you're
getting the office lunch, for MLK day.
- What?
- I just didn't want you
to seem racist, so...
- Oh.
- Thanks.
- Okay, I love MLK.
I love MLK.
(slow guitar plucking)
(candy wrappers rustling)
(pens clack)
(jar crashes)
- Harper, what are you doing?
- Shh, keep your mouth open.
Keep your mouth shut.
(slow guitar plucking)
- Hey boss, I told everyone
you're ordering the office
lunch, for Yom Kippur.
I didn't want you to like,
seem racist or anything.
Alright, thanks.
- But that's a fasting holiday.
(slow guitar plucking)
- Hey, Elliott, did you
get any of that gum?
- Oh, yeah, I got a whole pack.
- Ohh, perfect.
- Yeah, here ya go.
- I'll see ya later.
- Cool.
(slow guitar plucking)
- It's the best way to go.
- What's with the cupcakes?
- They're for your birthday.
- You know it's not my birthday.
Who told you that it was today?
- Harper did.
- You bought me cupcakes?
- Happy birthday.
- It's not my birthday,
you just wanted free food.
- Don't you have
a free cupcake
in your dainty little hand, Anna?
- Yeah, I do.
- Yeah.
And if you wanna keep
getting free cupcakes,
you'll keep your pretty little mouth shut.
- Okay.
(Spanish guitar)
- Happy birthday.
(slow guitar plucking)
- And I only had to pay for three.
- I haven't paid for anything since 1946.
(laughter)
- How old are you?
- Shh.
- Alright, that's a cut.
(string intruments playing)
(film reel clacking)
(modem beeps)